wednesday p-f-t-o-t
a little extra show that we can use to
discuss things we didn't get to during
pft live something that came up during
the program chris that i think merits
conversation and also careful evaluation
as the season
unfolds as training camp proceeds as
the patriots have meetings and as bill
belichick has ammunition
for critiquing the performances of new
quarterback cam newton
kyle love who played both with the
patriots when tom brady was there and
bill belichick coached him
and the panthers when cam newton was
there and ron rivera coached him kyle
love says he's got a concern
about whether and to what extent cam
newton will tolerate
the kind of candid coaching that
bill belichick used to routinely provide
to tom brady and i remember the story of
chad johnson being freaked out his first
day
with the patriots in 2011 after the
lockout when he was traded there
because belichick tore into brady for
his performance in the playoff loss the
prior
season to the jets randy moss went
through the same thing in 2007
belichick tears into tom brady when
belichick tears into cam newton i guess
the first question is
willie the second question is if he does
how will cam newton deal with it because
kyle love seems to think
that cam newton was a little coddled by
ron rivera and the panthers coaches yeah
well i think that's the sentiment around
the nfl
is that he was you know in carolina
that he was the first pick of the draft
he's super talented
you know he won some games
single-handedly you know with his pure
ability
and yeah in most places what that tends
to lead to
is a guy kind of becoming the king of
that team for lack of a better way to
put it
you know oh hey man he shows up on
sunday he's ready to go blah blah blah
right you know so then yes
you know naturally from there when
you're one of your best players coaches
the organization
they're very sensitive into making sure
that player
feels good on a daily basis and that's
my biggest concern
up in new england you know kyle love he
was in new england when i was there he's
a very smart
defensive player cerebral that way your
typical new england guy
but you know and he's got good
perspective here this was my biggest
concern
something i kind of discussed on my
podcast right when i when cam newton was
signed with new england mike is just
you know i've said it's 80 boom 20 bust
and my bust factor was yes
can he handle the everyday
you know rigors of the nfl
with the new england patriots and that
is yes
nobody being a cheerleader for you and
you make a 20 yard out throw and they
just go you know good
hey good throw cam it's not like all
right way to go oh hey whoa did you see
that throw everybody it's not gonna be
none of that
you know when you mess up it's gonna be
pointed out in front of the whole team
and there's gonna be some constructive
criticism that goes with that i don't
think he's gonna cuss out
cam newton like he did brady quite yet
he's probably gonna get to know the guy
but between that and just the attention
to detail
and the humbleness and do your job and
on to the next play
that is my question can cam newton
handle that day after day after day
because like you said
it kind of melted chad johnson albert
haynesworth
there's been players that go up there to
new england and we never hear from them
again
because of that aspect it's very real
reggie wayne right there for a couple of
weeks and decided to retire
right he had enough after all those
years in indianapolis where everything
was great he goes new england for just a
couple of weeks and football this isn't
fun they're not having fun here i'm out
here's what kyle loves said i don't feel
like cam can take the pressure
of coaches talking down about his play
if he had a bad game in carolina
the coaching staff wouldn't say much to
him because they may have felt
he could be a little frail about it or
maybe pout they never really co
corrected him to the point that bill
belichick used to correct tom brady i
think about the aftermath of super bowl
50.
remember he's he's in the yeah sure the
press conference you can hear chris
harris jr
crowing about what the broncos did to
panthers he gets up and walks out
i mean cam newton is always the guy
who's on that roller coaster where when
everything is going well
it's great it's the superman it's the
big smile and they just and everything
is great
and when it doesn't go great that's when
you have the demeanor it's just it's not
really my day that's kind of you can see
it on the field
the way he moves he just you know just
to get me the hell out of here and then
give me a give me another game that i
can start at 0-0
and try to make that my day uh
i i that makes me think the patriots are
going to adjust their approach
i think they're sure enough to recognize
it right when we sign
cam newton we're signing a guy who isn't
going to be
a sponge for any and all criticism and
that's not the way to get him to be the
best he can be
it was the way to get tom brady to be
the best he could be he pissed him off
and he tried to show us cam newton
that's not the way to make him the best
he can be
agreed and i would be shocked if that's
not the case like
hey back to our old you know wes welker
conversation right
they weren't coaching randy moss like
they were coaching wes welker
yeah they realized that was oh wes
welker
will tell them he's not good and
disrespect him and he'll play better
you know you can't do that to randy moss
he's a different guy so they had a
different approach
right and i think that between josh
mcdaniels and bill belichick first off
they're better communicators than they
get credit for you know yeah they're
kind of robots in the media so people
don't really get to see
how good they are in that aspect of
their job it's the thing i was blown
away by
being in new england you've heard me say
before the one thing that i just was
like shocked about is bill is much more
of a players coach than people realize
his door is always open to the players
he does a great job of getting around
talking to guys
the team loves bill he and then of
course he's
he's honest and at the end of the day a
lot of guys respect that
now yeah it's going to be a little
different from cam newton but i do think
josh mcdaniels and bill belichick
will know pretty early on and have also
we know done their research to know
all right do we think this guy's so
sensitive and such a diva
that he can't even come in here and and
react to our coaching
i think they've done their due diligence
to get the right answer there to where
they felt like you said no
we feel like he can and then they'll
find that right balance
of you know hey we're going to be
critical of the guy but we're not going
to crap all over him to where it ruins
the next two days of practice
they'll find that balance and and i
think cam newton i'm expecting because
of the trials and tribulations he's
gone through he'll bounce back and he
wants to prove everybody in a man on a
mission so we'll see where it goes
that's the key it is they have gotten
cam newton at a point where he
is beaten down he feels rejected
he feels disrespected maybe he should
have been one of the entries in our
draft today of the most disrespected
figures in the nfl no
crap we're idiots for that disrespectful
yeah the way the rest of the league
treated him and ignored him and now i
understand
circumstances made it difficult for
anyone to bring cam newton in and sign
he made it difficult to trade for made
it difficult to do anything
but the contract disrespects him the
fact that he had to wait so long
disrespects him but
what the patriots may be getting is a
guy that bill belichick could bring in
and
if this has probably already happened if
my guess here is even remotely accurate
it's already occurred
you have a heart-to-heart with the guy
yeah you say look
we have been watching you for the last
decade
we've seen you beat us twice pfd bingo
cam newton two and oh all time against
the new england patriots right we know
what you can do
and i know a thing or two about getting
the most out of guys
and i feel like nothing against your
coaching staff in carolina
they did you a disservice because they
didn't know how to get the most out of
you
i know how to get the most out of you
look here's tom brady here's tom brady
running
here's tom brady trying to evade the
pass rush here's tom brady
trying to slide here's all the things
tom brady can't do athletically i turned
that guy into the best quarterback in
nfl history
now here's what you can do right you buy
into this you do this the way that i
think we need to do it
there may be days where you want to
punch me in the face
but if i could do what i did with this
guy
show the photo of him at the scouting
combine where he looks like the 38 year
old guy with a prostate issue trying to
go to the bathroom at 3am
if i could do that with this guy just
think of what i can do with you
yeah that's the way i think to get him
to buy in and that's that's that's
you know belichick isn't inflexible like
you said
they coach randy moss one way they coach
wes welker another way they coach tom
brady one way
they're going to coach cam newton a
different way but i think they have a
unique opportunity
to get cam newton to sign on the dotted
line for what it's going to be like to
be a patriot yes i i agree
and i would think that some sort of
conversation like that has happened
you know yes uh and i'll tell you just
evidence that makes me believe
already that you know cam newton's
drinking the kool-aid and is all in
hey when he got off the plane in boston
and the way he handled the media he was
already in new england mode
to me that just sounded like bill's
talked to him
and already given them like hey this is
how i want you to act this is what i
want you to do
i believe in you and we're going to do
this around you to make you a better
player and
we're going to work and all that and cam
was like damn i like how that sounds
okay let's do that
and they'll build his confidence within
the realm of you know feeling confident
there in new england in that
offense too as we explained when he
first got signed
you know new england's not one of those
teams that's like here's a hundred plays
figure it out
no they're gonna they start with baby
steps five ten plays we're gonna master
it
we're gonna see which ones we're really
good at oh our quarterback's really good
at this and that
now let's start to build off of those
things he does really good
and then we'll in the meantime work on
some of the things he's not good at
but we're going to focus on this and
start formulating our offense around
those things he does good
and when you do that all of a sudden
practice goes good and cam newton's
throwing completions and he's going
damn i like this they're teaching me the
right way and people are open and all
that
and that's hopefully where it can build
into damn here he goes new england and
cam newton and
they didn't miss a beat and they're
still one of the best teams in the afc
yes all due respect to kyle love i think
it's not nearly as simple as it may
appear on the surface
i think there may be some tough love
yeah but i think that cam newton will
understand it and
and and maybe he's grown and matured to
the point where he realizes
he's not going to achieve his goals in
football without
something a little more aggressive than
what it is that he got nothing against
ron rivera
right ron rivera comes in as a
first-time head coach with the guy who
was the first overall pick in the draft
i think a certain relationship starts
and it stays that way
this is a different circumstance all
together for everyone involved and this
is grown man
cam newton who is desperate to win chris
and i think will deal with some coaching
that may be far more aggressive than
what he ever had in carolina so it's
gonna be fun to watch
it is hopefully he won't opt out with
all the patriots who are opting out
hopefully cam newton won't opt out
before tomorrow at 4 p.m eastern right
and i don't want to be flipping about it
whoever chooses to opt out i respect
their decision it is not an easy
decision
but that window closes at 4pm eastern on
thursday we're going to close our window
until
tomorrow thanks for some of your time as
always we'll be updating the nfl all day
long at profotballtalk.com have a great
day
we'll see you thursday see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports